let's say that f of x
is equal to the absolute value of x
minus 3
over
x minus 3 and what i'm curious about
is the limit
of f of x the limit of f x
as x approaches 3. and just from an
inspection you can see that the function
is not defined when x is equal to 3. you
get 0 over 0 it's not defined so to
answer this question let's try to
rewrite the same exact function
definition slightly differently so let's
say f of x
is going to be equal to and i'm going to
think of two cases i'm going to think of
the case when x is greater than 3 and
when x is less than 3. so when x is
just in two different colors actually
when x
do it in green
that's not green
when x is greater than 3 when x is
greater than 3 what does this function
simplify to
well whatever i get up here i'm just
taking the i'm going to get a positive
value up here and then i'm what if i
take the absolute value it's going to be
the exact same thing so let me for x is
greater than 3 this is going to be the
exact same thing as x minus 3
over x minus 3 because if x if x is
greater than 3 the numerator is going to
be positive you take the absolute value
of that you're not going to change its
value so you get this right over here or
if we were to rewrite it
if we rewrite it this is equal to for x
is greater than 3
you're going to have f of x is equal to
1 for x is greater than 3.
similarly let's think about what happens
when x is less than 3.
when x is less than 3
well x minus 3 is going to be a negative
number when you take the absolute value
of that you're essentially negating it
so it's going to be the negative of x
minus 3
over
x minus 3. or if you were to simplify
these two things for any value as long
as x does not equal 3 this part right
over here simplifies to 1 so you're left
with a negative 1. negative 1 for x is
less than 3. i encourage you if you
don't believe what i just said try it
out with some numbers try out some
numbers 3.1 3.001 3.547
any number greater than 3 you're going
to get 1. you're going to get the same
thing divided by the same thing and try
values for x less than three one you're
going to get negative one no matter what
you try so let's visualize this function
now
so now let me draw some axes
that's my x-axis
and then this is my
this is my f of x axis y is equal to f
of x
and what we care about is x is equal to
3 so x is equal to 1
4 5 we could keep going and let's say
this is positive 1 2
so that's y is equal to 1 this is y is
equal to negative 1 and negative 2 and
we can keep going so this this way that
we've rewritten the function is
the exact same function as this we've
just written in a different way and so
what we're saying is is where our
function is undefined at 3 but if our
x's are greater than 3 our function is
equal to 1. so if our x is greater than
3 our function is equal to 1. so it
looks like
it looks like
that and it's undefined at 3
and if x is less than 3 our function is
equal to negative 1. so it looks like
let me do that same color
it looks like this it looks like
it looks like this once again it's
undefined at 3.
so it looks like that so now let's try
to answer our question what is the limit
as x approaches 3
well let's think about the limit as x
approaches 3 from the negative direction
from values less than 3. so let's think
about first the limit
the limit as x approaches 3
as x approaches 3
at the limit of f of x as x approaches 3
from the negative direction and all this
notation here i wrote this negative as a
superscript right after the 3 says let's
think about the limit as we're
approaching let me make this clear let's
approaching from the left so in this
case if we get closer if if we get if we
start with values lower than three as we
get closer and closer and closer so say
we start at zero the f of x is equal to
negative one we go to one f of x is
equal to negative one we go to two f of
x is equal to negative one if you go to
2.99999 f of x is equal to negative 1.
so it looks like it is approaching
negative 1 if you approach if you
approach from the left hand side
now let's think about the limit
the limit of f x
the limit of f of x as x approaches 3
from the positive direction from values
greater than 3.
so here we see
when x is equal to 5 f of x is equal to
1. when f when x is equal to 4 f of x is
equal to 1. when x is equal to 3.00001
f of x is equal to 1. so it seems to be
approaching it seems to be approaching
positive 1.
so now we have something strange we seem
to be approaching a different value when
we approach from the left than when we
approach from the right
and if we're approaching two different
values then the limit does not exist
so this limit right over here does
does not
does
not
exist or another way of saying it
the limit
the limit of let me write this in a new
color i have a little idea here
the limit of
the limit of an of a function f of x as
x approaches some value c
is equal to l
if and only if
if and only if the limit
of f of x
as x approaches c from the negative
direction
is equal to the limit
of f of x as x approaches c from the
positive direction which is equal to l
this did not happen here the limit when
we approached from the left we was
negative one the limit when we
approached from the right was positive
one so we did not get the same limits
when we approach from either side so the
limit does not exist in this case